[Musique]
bonjour à tous très heureux de vous
retrouver sur Public Sénat pour une
nouvelle semaine d'examen de la réforme
des retraites ici à la Haute Assemblée
toute cette semaine vous pourrez suivre
en direct les échanges des sénateurs sur
notre antenne dans le cadre de nos
émissions spéciales et puis également
sur notre site internet public sénat.fr
avec de très bons articles de décryptage
on va tout de suite aller en séance dans
l'hémicycle du Sénat les sénateurs vont
débattre d'une proposition de la droite
de création d'un CDI senior pour inciter
à les entreprises à embaucher des
seniors et on commentera à ces débats
avec Quentin Calmet toute la journée
c'est parti pour une nouvelle semaine de
débat sur la forme des retraites au
Sénat
pour 2023 dans un parvenu à l'amendement
2112 rectifié qui tente à insérer
l'article additionnelle après l'article
règlement madame rossignol
mon rappel au règlement se font de sur
les articles 8 tu prends en bulle de 46
et 55 de la Constitution il concerne
donc chacun leur a compris l'exercice du
droit de grève en France de
monsieur le ministre vous appliquez la
règle du 30e indivisible c'est-à-dire
que en ce qui concerne les
fonctionnaires d'État pour deux heures
de grève il l'aurait retiré une journée
de salaire cette règle est une règle
spécifiquement appliquée au
fonctionnaires de la fonction publique
d'État puisqu'elle n'est pas appliquée
dans ces termes-là ni aux fonctionnaires
de la fonction publique hospitalière ni
au sud ni à ceux de la fonction publique
territoriale or il se trouve que le
Conseil de l'Europe a été chargé
d'examiner la compatibilité là le
respect par cette règle du droit de
grève qui est garantie par la Charte
sociale européenne et il a rendu sa
décision il y a quelques jours et cette
décision est très claire la règle du 30e
indivisible viol l'article 6 paragraphe
4 de la Charte sociale européenne donc
que Monsieur le Ministre comptez-vous
mettre fin à cette règle discriminatoire
discriminatoire entre les différents
fonctionnaires d'une part et
discriminatoires à l'encontre des
salariés de la fonction publique qui use
de l'endroit de grève je vous pose cette
question aujourd'hui parce qu'elle est
particulièrement importante la veille
d'un mouvement social qui à la fois va
être très fort contre votre réforme et
qui en même temps se situe dans un
contexte particulier qui est celui d'une
inflation importante et de pression
forte sur le pouvoir d'achat donc
monsieur le ministre je comprends bien
l'intérêt vicieux qu'il pourrait y avoir
à compter sur les difficultés
financières des fonctionnaires pour
espérer qu'il renonce à exercer leur
droit de grève demain mais je n'imagine
pas que le gouvernement puisse se livrer
à un calcul aussi sordide donc il serait
bon que aujourd'hui vous annoncer au
fonctionnaires que ceux qui feront grève
quelques heures demain ne se verront pas
retirer la totalité de leur journée de
travail mais simplement leurs heures de
grève
et donner de ce rappel au règlement nous
allons examiner un amendement essai de
sous un amendement qui vont faire
l'objet d'une discussion
commune
un amendement
2112 rectifiés
monsieur le rapporteur
bien merci monsieur le Président on
attaque dans le vif du sujet en ce qui
concerne notre stratégie d'emploi des
seniors là
amendement porte sur les seniors au
chômage 2 milliards consacrés par
lunédique pour les chômeurs de plus de
60 ans ça doit quelque part nous
interpeller donc ce qui veut dire que
les outils actuels d'emploi des seniors
ne sont pas suffisants c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous avons sur proposition
de longues de partenaires sociaux
proposés ce CDI senior le CDI senior
c'est quoi c'est un CDI différent
réservé un contrat entre le salarié et
son employeur pour que on définisse les
conditions de travail le les durées de
travail pour aller jusqu'au taux plein
de départ en retraite du salarié le taux
plein voulant dire être acquis à la fois
par les nombres de trimestres ou
éventuellement avec l'âge d'annulation
de la décote c'est tout à fait différent
de ce qui existe actuellement puisque
les CDI classique peuvent toujours être
utilisés mais sont pas suffisants
puisque on constate que il y a
effectivement un taux de chômage aux
alentours de la soixantaine qui est
particulièrement important c'est pour ça
qu'on veut se doter d'outils nouveaux
pour inciter pour inciter l'employeur
nous proposons un exonération de
cotisations familiales de façon à ce
qu'il y ait une incitation à aller
plutôt sur ce CDI très spécifique
négocier avec le salarié par rapport à
ces traditionnel et pour le salarié ça
me paraît intéressant puisque on adapte
les conditions de travail en fonction
effectivement de son âge ou des
phénomènes d'usure c'est la raison pour
laquelle ce CDI peut être dès à présent
me semble-t-il inscrit dans la loi et je
ne vous demande de le soutenir de façon
à ce qu'ensuite et c'est notre
préoccupation il soit discuté avec les
partenaires sociaux dans le cadre des
négociations pour qu'il puisse être
adopté prise en main par les partenaires
sociaux je vous remercie
sous abondement madame Lubin que vous
présentez
oui merci monsieur le Président en fait
nous aurions enfin nous comprenons bien
l'objectif de de cette proposition de
notre de notre rapporteur
mais il y a un certain nombre de choses
sur lesquelles nous ne sommes pas
d'accord sur le contenu de ce contrat je
pense que nous aurons l'occasion d'en
débattre avec monsieur le rapporteur qui
nous apportera
ses réponses en attendant nous avons
souhaité poser un amendement qui propose
juste certes de remplacer les mots
derniers fin de carrière par dernier
embauche mais ça peut paraître anodin
mais ça ne l'est pas c'est parce qu'en
fait dans ce qui est proposé ce qui nous
dérange par exemple c'est la possibilité
à un employeur de mettre fin au contrat
de travail dès que si j'ai bien compris
le salarié atteindrait la possibilité le
niveau auquel il devrait il pourrait
valider sa retraite et ça ça nous ça ça
nous paraît sous couvert d'une
proposition je le sais
qui est sincère ça nous paraît pouvoir
être comment dire un outil
supplémentaire pour des employeurs de
recruter des gens qu'on garde finalement
le moins longtemps possible mais on aura
l'occasion d'en discuter merci monsieur
le Président
Monsieur Dufour le présent
le président de mes chers collègues donc
il est proposé en septembre
pour les mesures de signative à l'emploi
de remettre large 55 ans au lieu de 60
tels que prévu par le par le texte
monsieur Hainaut présente tous ces
amendement 2343 oui merci monsieur le
Président si vous le voulez bien j'ai
évoqué les deux dans la même
argumentation parce qu'ils sont très
très proches et il se suivent monsieur
messieurs les ministres
je vais pas reprendre l'argumentation du
rapporteur je pense que nous sommes tous
d'accord pour dire que l'emploi des
seniors est un défi pour notre société
c'est aussi une question à résoudre si
on veut équilibrer notre système de
répartition et bien évidemment que ce
soit sur le plan économique financier et
surtout morale ça ne peut pas être la
variable d'ajustement des des
entreprises notre interrogation elle est
sur la bardage puisque même dans votre
argumentation hier monsieur le
rapporteur vous évoquait les vous
évoquez les 55 74 ans ou le 57
64 ans est-ce que la barre pertinente et
60 ans nous voulons lancer le débat sur
l'idée que ça pourrait être 57 ans et
qui pourrait y avoir une disposition
progressive
25% d'exonération puis 50 puis 75 et
puis 100% voilà nous souhaitons ce débat
sur l'âge pertinent pour ce